Klout score is the single number that, that measure your influence across the
Internet primarily the social media. I'm Chief Scientist at Klout, I run the
data science team as well as the data infrastructure team oversee all the data
driven products that come, you know kind of lead the team behind the score. >>
And you created the whole infrastructure, and the algorithm behind the Klout
score, right? >> I create the infrastructure and the science behind the Klout
score. We grade everyone's influence on the Internet from a scale from 1 to 99.
It's a single score that you can see as your credit score for you online
reputation or you know, a single score that you can measure influence with.
Klout score is calculate by incorporating all your data from various social
networks, ranging from Twitter to Facebook, to LinkedIn. And for each network, I
would collect about a hundred signals. Number of retweets you get per twwet,
number of likes you get per post on Facebook stuff like that are all the signals
that we look at overall we consifer four hundred signals per person. And we
generally scores for 400 million and more users at everyday. Klout score follows
this by model distribution, where you have this very big peak of users who are
in this 40 to 60s on this side and also the users who are quality content
producers. And you also have this very nice peak of users on the other side who
are the consumers of those content. And if you, you know, plot the score, and
the number of users with each score buckets from this side to this side. You
know, this is zero, and that's 99. And this, you know, the y axis is the number
of users who are in this buckets. You can see a very nice by model distribution
there. The average cost score is lower than the median because they are
proportionally more people with a lower score, so they drag the average down. So
in such a distribution, taking a look at the median makes more sense. Being able
to beat forty is actually a pretty good sign of being very influential on the
social media.